صراع متجمد بين صربيا وكوسوفو يذوب عنه
الجليد من وقت لاخر مع اي شراره بسيطه
توترات جديده اذا اندلعت هذا الاسبوع بعد
مواجهات بين الشرطه في كوسوفو وقوات حفظ
السلام التابعه للنيتو من جهه وبين صرب
كوسوفو من جهه ثانيه تمديد كالعاده هو
الموقف الاوروبي الثابت من التوترات بين
صربيا وكوسوفو السعيتين للانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوازات بوريل مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في اوروبا ادانا اعمال العنف
التي قد تؤدي لاوضاعا خطيره للغايه منتظرا
تدابير فوريه من الطرفين لنزع الفتيل لكن
الازمه لا تقتصر على حدود البلدين بل ترمي
بثقل تداعياتها على الاتحاد الاوروبي خبر
الاكده ان اوروبا لا تتحمل صراعا اخر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات